[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
May 22nd I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
starting next year the amount that
people can contribute to their health
savings account will rise substantially
wsj personal finance reporter Ashley
Ebling is with us to discuss why this
largest ever increase is being put in
place and how it can help you manage
your medical expenses so first of all
Ashley what is a health savings account
or HSA and what does it allow people to
do an HSA is a account that you can pair
with a high deductible Health Care
insurance plan so if you pick the high
deductible plan you can get this HSA and
it helps take the sting out of having
the high deductible basically you get an
immediate tax benefit just from putting
money into the account and pulling it
out immediately to spend on health care
expenses and there's an added benefit
you can invest the money and hopefully
see it grow before you spend it some
people have been contributing to the
accounts of build up balances of tens of
thousands of dollars so how does
somebody open up an HSA typically you do
it through your employer when you sign
up for your health insurance you would
sign up for the HSA at the same time but
you can also just do it on your own so
you don't have to be working for an
employer to have an HSA right if you're
self-employed you'd have your health and
high deductible health care plan and
then there's a list of HSA providers and
if you're doing it that way it's really
important to look at fees and what their
investment options are so starting next
year the maximum HSA contribution will
be 8 300 for a family and four thousand
one hundred and fifty dollars for an
individual and it's even more for people
55 and older why is the IRS ramping up
these contribution levels so much so
basically Congress set the base
contribution limits and said they should
be adjusted for inflation so every year
the IRS looks at that and tweaks the
contribution limits based on inflation
obviously inflation's been really high
so the limits have gone up typically the
bumps just 100 or 200 a year if at all
some years it's zero but because because
of high inflation
this year the family maximum limit went
up 450 dollars to 2023 and then next
year it's going up 550 for 2024. what
kinds of medical expenses are typically
eligible to be paid for by an HSA if
you're paying out of pocket medical
expenses without HSA you're paying too
much or you're overpaying basically so
Medicare Part B premiums would count
they run almost four thousand dollars
for a married couple with income up to
194 thousand dollars this year so that's
a big one um but for everyone else it's
all deductibles all co-pays Vision
Dental hearing expenses even long-term
care even things when you go to the
drugstore like sunscreen but can't
people tap into their 401k or their Ira
for medical expenses how is this
different so you can tap into 401ks and
IRAs but that's not until you're 59 and
a half when you're older the point is
now with the hsas you can use it for
everyday expenses now and save money
you're contributing on a pre-tax basis
there's no tax going in there's tax-free
growth and tax-free withdrawals whenever
you take the money out so it's really a
triple tax advantage account and
financial advisors see the hsas as a
compliment to your 401k Ira in the sense
that you can keep the money there and
have it grow and then use it for retiree
health care expenses so there's that you
know give and take depending when you
need the money you can take it out
earlier or later so from an investment
standpoint in the way that you would
invest the money in it how does an HSA
differ from say a 401k so typically with
a 401k your employer will have a lineup
of Target date funds or other options
that you can invest in it there's a
default investment they would put you in
and HSA is different because in most
plans there's a deposit account just a
checking account to start with and then
once you reach a thousand dollar
threshold then you can start investing
so you're kind of driving the investment
lineup more with an HSA it's up to you
you really have to pay attention to it
to make sure you're investing because I
talked to one HSA account holder he
retired he had actually accumulated
twenty six thousand dollars in his HSA
but it had just been left in that
checking account basically not earning
any interest to speak of and then now
that he's retired he's paying attention
to it he's rolled it over to Fidelity
where he's investing earning 4.5 percent
you know there's a lot of acronyms we're
talking about here Ashley how does an
HSA differ from a flexible spending
account or FSA that a lot of people have
so the big is this idea that the HSA is
yours to keep even after you leave an
employer so it's a long-term account
fsas have much lower contribution limits
and you lose them when you lose your
employer they're basically annual
accounts you can roll over only a
limited amount from one year to the next
if at all and what happens to the health
savings account money you have HSA at
the end of a year at the end of a
calendar year it's there it rolls over
it's like your 401k if you've been
invested you might see the balance going
up and down but you don't lose it that's
Ashley Ebling personal finance reporter
with us and that's your money briefing
I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall Street
Journal
foreign